do you get anxiety do you get depression
do you have things that you do for it uh
do you go to therapy what is it that you
how do you deal with things how do you
deal with life rejection yeah it helps
it helps to create a philosophy for
yourself where it's just like do or die
where you're just like
okay whether
like when I set out to be an actor I was
like
I don't care if I make a penny at this
I'm gonna be doing this till I'm 99
years old on the side of a road with a
hat just being like hello my baby you
know it's like doing like oh like tap
dancing for people and like you know I
really really that's true like if you
were making no money you wouldn't have
quit eventually you would have get you
wouldn't have given up you would have
kept doing uh a Repertory Theater
whatever it was
until I died
I would have just kept acting
yeah because
um
I don't know man I just like
it was it's my jam like it's like like
if I like I don't know like if I
couldn't act I would be doing some other
right brain thing
you know like that doesn't make money
like sculpting on the side of the road
you are a sculptor you're a Sculptor
yeah but like you know it's you know
it's a hobby but um wait if I offered
you 50 million dollars cash 50 million
and I said you can never act again
oh
[__] it's kind of sad here's 50 million
you can never act again no never act
again
holy crap
I'd have to talk to my wife for that
we can act in front of each other nope
can't even act in front of each other
that's incredible you can't even pretend
to like things
wow 50 million it's a lot of money I
don't know man
feel like I would still like sneak away
and make
films like secret films to feed the
beast in my belly God yeah that's
amazing no that's amazing that you even
ponder that because if somebody said
I'll give you five I'd be like [__] yeah
five million I'm done let's move on to
uh I'll direct I'll uh I'll do whatever
I'll travel
I don't know I still got something to
prove like like if I had done like
if I had gotten to this point and you
offered me the same thing and I'd be
like oh yeah I've done all my favorite
roles and all the things I wanted to do
and you know then I would say like yeah
I guess I could step away from
from acting and that would be a kind of
like a rock and roll kind of thing and
just live you know uh but I haven't I
haven't but wait you just said I I have
to I still have to prove do you have to
prove to yourself or do you have to
prove to everyone else be honest because
a lot of it's like I want to show you
that I'm a [__] brilliant actor or do
you want to just prove to yourself too
that you're capable of doing that
I know I'm capable of doing it I I know
I know like because like I said like in
in college like
I did the full spectrum
of like I I had like a a really good
idea of what my abilities were in
college
as
what I would call
um a sad clown the kind of actor that
can make you cry in one sentence and
make you sad and it make you happy in
the next sentence
um and
that's what I always wanted to be
watching
uh actors like Robin Williams who I love
and uh may he rest in peace and like I
was like not that I'm anywhere near the
quickness of Robin or his talent but I
was I would strive to be like him
and
um I knew in college that I like I was
like oh I can make people laugh and I
can make people cry
and
I've been given chances to do that in
certain roles over the years but I
haven't there's certain roles that I've
always wanted to play and there are
certain roles
that like I haven't been I haven't
stretched my I haven't stretched all the
muscles that I stretched in college you
know for yeah this audience yet that I
have their attention you know and I and
so I want them to see
the full spectrum and then
um you can judge my career or my
abilities on that
and then I'll take you 50 minutes I knew
you're gonna say it